Star-studded casts, pandemic nightmares,
and a puppet that cost more than a mansion:
Can TV shows possibly get
more expensive than this?
Taking the grand prize for the most expensive
television production to date is The Lord of
the Rings: The Rings of Power, which came
in at a whopping $58 million per episode.
An epic high fantasy series based on the world
of J. R. R. Tolkien, The Rings of Power takes
place millennia before the events of The Hobbit
and The Lord of the Rings. When the rights to
a Tolkien TV series first went up for grabs, a
bidding war erupted between major streamers HBO,
Amazon, and Netflix, with Amazon beating out
its rivals with a hefty bid of $250 million.
"This could be the beginning of a new era."
In a world of AR sound stages and green screens,
The Rings of Power stands out for its elaborate
sets and on-location shoots, which production
designer Ramsey Avery says are meant to capture
the golden age of Middle-Earth, long before
Sauron's villainous shenanigans start to drag
everything down. Factor in the elaborate
costumes and full-scale ensemble cast,
and you've got a recipe for the
priciest series ever made — in fact,
with a grand total of five seasons ordered
and already planned in their entirety,
the show's total budget could come
in at more than a billion dollars.
At a time when Netflix has been
tightening its purse strings,
one show that the platform has funneled endless
money into is the hit supernatural sci-fi series
Stranger Things. Since the show's $6
million per episode freshman season,
Netflix has gradually increased its
budget while continuing to ramp up the
killer computer-generated and practical
effects. Not only that, but, by 2018,
several of the show's cast were taking home
paychecks of around $250K–$350K per episode.
It's estimated that the price tag for the fourth
season came in at around $30 million per episode.
According to Netflix executive Ted Sarandos,
a hefty chunk of Season 4's spending
increase can be attributed to COVID,
which, between the need for extra protocols and
production shutdowns, hit the budget hard. Still,
it was money well spent. The show features
some of the most beautiful CGI out there and
is a testament to the truly cinematic quality
a well-executed streaming series can have. This
attention to detail even earned Stranger Things
the Emmy for best prosthetic makeup in 2022.
The second prequel to Taylor Sheridan's hit
series Yellowstone, 1923 follows the Dutton
family during the tumultuous years leading
up to the Great Depression. Comparing his
latest show to Lawrence of Arabia in
terms of scale, Sheridan told Deadline:
"I don't know what the Game
of Thrones budgets were,
but I don't know how they could
have been more than this."
One of the show's big-ticket items is its cast, an
ensemble led by Hollywood legends Helen Mirren and
Harrison Ford — but this is just the beginning.
To create the sense of life on a Montana ranch,
the series uses thousands of real cattle
and sheep. And much of 1923 was filmed in
a span of overseas locations, including
Malta, Tanzania, Kenya, and South Africa.
Filming during the pandemic also meant that COVID
protocols upped the budget even further. Then,
of course, you've got the added cost of
a historical series — it's no mean feat
to build and dress sets for a show set
100 years in the past. The grand total
for this gorgeously rendered drama comes
in at around $30 million per episode.
"It's time. Alright, okay? Let's give 'em hell."
The MCU Disney+ series Hawkeye racked up a $150
million price tag during its six-episode run,
which comes out at around $25 million per episode.
For the sake of comparison, Captain Marvel,
one of Marvel's theatrical releases, boasted a
budget of around $152 million. As with many other
big-budget TV shows, one of Hawkeye's major
costs was its star power: Jeremy Renner, who
reprises his role as the titular Avenger, is one
of the higher-paid actors in the Marvel universe.
While his salary for the series isn't widely
known, Parade reported that the actor made $15
million for Avengers: Endgame and likely took home
a similar paycheck for Hawkeye. As the series was
primarily filmed in New York City, Georgia, and
Ontario, they weren't exactly dropping much of
the budget on hauling an entire cast and crew
from one exotic location to the next. However,
as is the case with many MCU shows and movies,
Hawkeye will have required a significant amount
of CGI, which always ramps up the budget. Judging
by the controversy stemming from the disappointing
effects in Episode 3, however, as well as greater
complaints about pay and working conditions from
Marvel VFX teams, it seems that this is one area
in which the franchise shouldn't be cutting costs.
As the first Marvel series to be released on
Disney+, and the first of the MCU's Phase Four,
WandaVision was a much-hyped and well-received
entry into the Marvel canon. Like the comics
themselves, the MCU keeps things fresh by serving
up a variety of genres and storytelling styles,
and WandaVision is a stunning example
of this. Starring Elizabeth Olsen as
Wanda Maximoff and Paul Bettany as
Vision, the series finds the pair
trapped in a strange alternate reality
that looks and feels like a laugh-track
sitcom. As the episodes progress, the pair
transitions from one decade to the next,
traveling through sets inspired by some of
the 20th century's most beloved TV shows.
"We are an unusual couple, you know."
"Oh, I don't think that was ever in question"
Like other Marvel shows, WandaVision was given
a generous budget of about $25 million per
episode — and it shows. Besides the lead duo's
inevitably impressive earnings, the show featured
400 shots of VFX created by a team of 100 or
so compositors. The sequence in which Vision
flies around Westview, for example, took months to
produce… and effects like that don't come cheap.
Yet another entry in Marvel's Disney+ line-up,
Loki finds the God of Mischief joining the Time
Variance Authority to repair the damage to the
timeline caused when he swiped the Tesseract
in Avengers: Endgame. This wickedly fun time
travel twister is one of the best recent
offerings from Marvel Studios, although,
with a budget of about $25 million per
episode, it certainly wasn't cheap.
As you've probably guessed, Loki stars Tom
Hiddleston as the MCU's favorite trickster,
and, considering he was reported to have been paid
$8 million for his very brief role in Avengers:
Infinity War, it's safe to say that a decent chunk
of the show's budget went toward his paycheck. All
that money at least seems to have paid off,
however: Many fans and critics agreed that
the series felt more like a film than a TV show,
and the first season was nominated for six Emmys,
including one for costumes and another
for outstanding production design.
Perhaps unsurprisingly, The Falcon and the Winter
Soldier enjoyed a comparable budget to WandaVision
and Loki at around $25 million per episode. The
show takes place a few months after Avengers:
Endgame, which ended with Sam Wilson taking
up Captain America's shield. Anthony Mackie
and Sebastian Stan reprised their roles from
the movies, and the show didn't exactly skimp
on its supporting cast, either. Not only
that, but The Falcon and the Winter Soldier
was partly filmed in the Czech Republic, and
the COVID outbreak of 2020 completely halted
production for several months too, likely adding
a significant number to the show's final cost.
While some critics felt the show's early
pacing could have been better, overall,
it drew praise for its social commentary and
the chemistry between its leading actors.
Falcon and the Winter Soldier's budget
is clearly well-spent too, making it an
enjoyable series overall — even if it isn't the
strongest limited series Marvel has produced.
These days, a blockbuster movie budget is hardly
a rarity in the world of TV production. In 2001,
however, it was practically unheard of.
Produced by Steven Spielberg and Tom Hanks,
Band of Brothers was the most expensive
television production to date with a budget
of $125 million — which would be closer to
$200 million today. The ten-part miniseries
follows Easy Company, a group of World War II
paratroopers from the 101st Airborne Division,
from training through their deployment on D-Day
and, ultimately, to the very end of the war.
A large portion of Band of Brothers' budget went
to support the massive ensemble cast, many of whom
were relatively unknown at the time of filming but
have since gone on to become famous faces today.
"Looks like you guys are gonna be surrounded."
"We're paratroopers, lieutenant.
We're supposed to be surrounded."
In the interest of depicting the war as accurately
as possible, the filmmakers and cast consulted
many of Easy Company's surviving veterans,
invested in authentic uniforms and equipment,
and poured plenty of cash into realistic
pyrotechnics. The effort paid off,
with many World War II veterans and
history experts alike agreeing that
the series presented one of the most accurate
portrayals of World War film ever produced.
The Pacific is a 2010 production that serves
as a companion piece to Band of Brothers.
Much like its older sibling, The Pacific
became the most costly television series
ever produced at the time of its release
— in total, HBO spent around $217 million.
According to co-executive producer Tony To, the
commitment to realistically filming battle scenes
was tremendous. Take the landing at Peleliu,
for example, which took four days to film and
came in under budget at around $5 million.
The scene featured upwards of 300 actors,
each of whom was clad in perfectly
duplicated 1940s military uniforms
that had been faithfully crafted on period looms.
On top of the costs of working with a large cast,
producers had to factor in pricey practical
effects, props, and pyrotechnics, with production
costs coming in at around $270,000 per filming
day. Fortunately, producers were able to cash in
on rebates by filming in Australia, slashing
the show's total cost by about $20 million.
House of the Dragon is a prequel to HBO's absurdly
successful fantasy drama series Game
of Thrones. And, like Game of Thrones,
House of the Dragon features an extra-large
ensemble cast of several dozen actors,
many of whom were already well-established
names when filming began. The first season's
budget was around $200 million, which comes out
to about $20 million per episode. In comparison,
the budget for the final season of Game of
Thrones was around $15 million per episode.
Fans of George R.R. Martin will be glad to
know that Westeros is getting the treatment
it deserves after cost-cutting led to some
not-so-flattering moments in Game of Thrones,
with Martin noting the first season's
small-scale jousting tournament as a
particular disappointment. Judging by the
incomparable tourney in House of the Dragon,
it's clear that the producers are going out of
their way to avoid making the same mistake twice.
The first of several live-action Star
Wars shows to be released on Disney+,
The Mandalorian is a space western set
a few years after Return of the Jedi.
"This is the way."
A few factors accounted for the show's price tag,
which equated to roughly $15 million per episode
— not least of which was its production studio.
The Mandalorian was the first series to pioneer
StageCraft technology, a type of all-around
AR wall that allows actors to work against
computer-generated backdrops. A key benefit of
this technology is that it creates more realistic
lighting rather than forcing the VFX team to
duplicate it when working with a green screen.
Among the show's more surprising expenses
was Grogu. Rather than dump a creepy CGI
creature into the series, producers chose
to go old-school Star Wars with a twist,
by investing in a foot-tall robotic puppet
— one that cost $5 million to build.
The Book of Boba Fett is a Disney+ Star
Wars series that serves as a spin-off
to The Mandalorian. The story follows the iconic
bounty hunter Boba Fett as he takes over Jabba the
Hutt's criminal organization on Tatooine. While
the seven-episode series wasn't as well-received
as The Mandalorian, it came with a similar
price tag of around $15 million an episode.
While The Book of Boba Fett doesn't have
a multi-million dollar puppet on deck,
it does have its own costly mascot of sorts in
the uncannily young Luke Skywalker. Although
de-aging technology is improving as it becomes
more widely used, it remains a costly investment
for any production. Besides smoothing out the
effects of time with CGI, the show's many tech
experts also used an application called
Respeecher to rewind time on Luke's voice,
since vocal cords tend to change over time. The
final result? Well, the jury's out on that one.